so first of all let me thank all the
organizers for the opportunity of
speaking here
and so okay today I'm reporting on this
on a joint work together with yachimi
Alicia
Pedro Marshall and Cristiano Ronaldo
that it's about the cactus variety of
cubic forms in particular I will show
you a theorem on the dimension of the
cactus variety of cubic forms and I will
underline in particular the the idea of
the apollar scheme artinian gorins and
Rings okay
rings
so
I will start with a brief introduction I
mean since Yara gave already many a big
part of this introductions I will recall
the wording Rank and the cactus rank
what they are and then I State the
theorem then I need few tools one is the
polarity that chiaric already said
something but also some days ago we I
think Enrico presented it
and then I have to also say what the
local Opera scheme is and then I can go
into the detail of the proof of the
theorem
so for me f is an homogeneous polynomial
of degree D
and the
the field has to be all directly closed
and they just need the characteristic is
not two or three I mean this condition
won't ever show up and they will in the
world talk I just stayed I just put it
because we need it in the in the in the
theorem because we we use another
theorem where there is this condition
but we will never use this
so what's the word in rank once again we
have an homogeneous polynomial of degree
D and the worrying rank is the minimum
in the there are such that F can be
written as the sum of our Pure powers of
linear forms okay so that's the the
worrying Rank and that's the definition
so I want to rephrase this definition by
using the veronese map the Vernon is a
map it takes a linear form and is sent
to into its pure power so the image of
this map is the Veronica variety so
every point in the Veronica variety is
the pure power of a linear form so
saying that F can be written as this
linear combination means that our f is
in the linear span of R Points in the
veronese of Rights so it belongs to an
earth secant space Sovereign variety
but it means also that here so the the
Veronica map starts from linear forms
and go into polynomials of degree D it
also means that in the space of linear
formulas I have R Points that are sent
in these are points here whose span
contains my f
so a complete way of saying this is that
that exists a scheme
finite so points
smooth so simple points of length R so
they are R Points
whose span I mean whose image whose
version is the image
and the span and F is contained in this
pen okay
so for me when every time I say scheme
for you have to think a scheme as set of
points and every time I say smooth it
means there are simple points so now
what I want to do is to remove the word
smooth from this definition
and if I remove the word smooth from
this definition you already know from
the previous talk you get the definition
of cactus rank so the cactus rank of f
is the minimum R such that there exists
a finite scheme in the space of linear
form that is sent by the veronese
variety and another scheme here whose
span contain f
so what's changing is that my points now
are not simple anymore I mean they're
not distant points but they can
like I can have multiple points any on
each support I put here in the bracket
the word gorenstein but I don't need it
in the definition it will turn out that
they are going sin but we will come back
on that
so
uh
now if I look at this at the the variety
parameterizing all the power all the the
polynomial of rank r i get the the
secant variety of the veronese
um
and here I have this word smooth and as
I said if I remove the word smooth I get
the the cactus shrank and so if I take
the same definition removing the word
smooth I get the cactus variety of the
veronese variety
so the cactus variety is the closure of
the Union of all the span of this needy
gamma where gamma is a scheme of length
r
and that's it
okay
so what I want to prove is to what I
want to show you is the dimension of
this variety
in the case of degree three when the
veteranism bedding is three
is cubic forms okay so okay we focus on
cubics and the theorem that I want to
prove is the following
whenever r r is the the length of the
scheme is more or equal than 17 these
two varieties are the same
clearly by the definition of the secant
and the cactus I mean since from this
definition and remove the word smooth
this variety is contained in this
variety I think Cactus varieties are
reducible
coverage games
okay then go back to the next slide so
whenever the r is more or equal than 17
these two varieties are the same
question which is
I'm sorry I'm sorry the dimension are
the same okay
they're not the same yes yeah okay thank
you thank you thank you yeah the
dimension of these two variety are the
same okay good
and for this we actually had to care
about for R bigger than 13 because for
hours we're already gone down 13 there
was already a paper and I mean it's a
preprint of because not you know Italian
where they showed that any local scheme
is multiple if R is monorical than 13.
and
am I right
local gorenstein scheme is movable
yeah I didn't take care of this because
in my talk everything is Corsten sorry
yeah
um
so okay so now so in our case we have to
take care only for our bigger bigger
than 13. and if R is two n plus two
then the cactus is Gonna Fill the
ambient space
and if R is in between 18 and 2 N plus
two then there we have is a strict
inequality here
I know you want to speak this episode
but
so is it that you can restrict attention
to gorenstein schemes or that these
things are automatically Gordon Stein
yes things are automatically algorithmic
you choose if you Choose Wisely
sorry
and this is the dimension okay okay
so I need some tools the first one is
the polarity
so what's a polarity once again a
polarity is a sort of Duality between
two spaces of polynomials as some T and
I want to think t as the partial
derivative on S so I want to act t on S
as the partial derivation almost almost
as partial derivation as you see here I
don't have any coefficient
so I'm using the divided power ring this
is only because of that condition of
characteristic to not to be two and
three but even if you are thinking to
your favorite complex numbers it's fine
even if you take the part the standard
partial derivation
and so with this action the degree one
part of this of these two spaces they
are dual spaces to each other and I can
think teen as the naturally coordinate
ring of PS1
so now I give two definitions one is the
polar ideal so if I have a polynomial F
in s
I defined a polar ideal to be what to be
the purp via this action so the set of
all partials so it's it sits here the
set of all partial that vanish that when
I apply them to F's I get zero
and I also Define the apolar scheme to F
and a polar scheme to F
so gamma is inside PS1 and is a polar
it's a scheme and it's a polar 2f if
it's representing ideal it's contained
in f-purp
so with this two definition I can say
rephrase and the polarity Lemma that
Enrico told us yesterday
and I can say that the scheme is a polar
2f to a form F if and only if f is
contained in the linear span of its
veronese image
so now you see with this two definitions
and this Lemma I can rephrase the
definition of cactus rank
and I can say that so we said the cactus
shrunk was the the minimum R such that
there exists a scheme here such that F
belongs to the span of its veronese
imagine
but for what we said of the polarity
Lemma this is the same thing of saying
that gamma is a polar to f
that the same thing by definition of
saying that the ideal of gamma is
contained in f-verb
okay
so these are the tools of the polarity
that I wanted to to show and then now it
we passed the other tool that star that
our local polar scheme
so if I look at this ring
I look at T over F purpose so these are
partials these are the partial
definition F on F so these are the
partials of f actually it turns out this
is proved by European and kind of that
it's local artinian gorenstein
and so I what I want to stress is the
fact that it's local
the fact that it's local means that is
supported at some points
okay
so I have my f
I look at the minimala polar scheme I
know that it's locally gorenstein
locally means it is supported at some
point I have this gamma eye that so each
of this gamma I is supported at one
single point
so it means that my f in general is in
the span the black one of both I mean
here I took just to two points but I
mean of the scheme is in the span of
this of this scheme
but also I can find any a polynomial in
in the span of each one of this
such that their combination gives
capital f
I like an even more General
so so in fact any local arterial
gorenstein scheme is the affine
a polar scheme to a polynomial Gene
okay meaning that
if if for that for any local Latino
algorithms in scheme okay here I'm
taking the a fine space
there existed a g that is a fine such
that the ideal what I'm questioning by
it's the purp of that g
Okay so I have my f my f is defines
certain gamma is the minimum local
abortion system
gamma is supported on points local
and Gamma I'm I've just said that he's
defined by a fine polynomials
each of these gamma eyes is defined by a
fine polynomials
so the first thing that I want to do to
prove this theorem is to understand the
link between the F and the gi's
okay no now I want to understand this
link so G now is not homogeneous anymore
I'm gonna call so this is the degree
Zero part of G it is a degree D part of
g d plus one and so on I'm gonna call
its lowest degree D part the degree
detail of G
and the link between capital F and the
GI is showed by this proposition so I
have my polynomial F of degree d i
de-omogenize it by some linear form now
I've taken like zero but it I can take
another linear form
let gamma be a scheme of minimal length
among those that are supported at the
linear form that I've used to
de-omogenize F the same one
the telepora 2f
okay maybe it's not the minimala polar
scheme to have because I'm I want that
is support to tell maybe it has a bigger
length with respect to all the polar
scheme to have but among those that are
supported at all I'm taking the minimal
one
one of the minimal one so gamma we have
already said is the final product
schemes with polynomial G that is a fine
and the the fact is that g
as the same degree the degree detail of
G is exactly F small F the
demogenization of capital F by this
linear function
so clearly this
is not unique but
this is saying that I can choose G in
such a way that I mean there are many
G's that defines the amenities that
defines gamma but this is saying that I
can choose G in such a way G as the same
degree detail of f i mean the degree
detail of G IS F
so
just the idea of the proof of this
proposition so first I want to Define
what I call the natural a polar scheme
of F at l
so as I said I can have many polynomials
that are polar to have supported at l
but is there some one of them that is
natural so I call it natural this one so
ideomogenize my capital F I take the
purp of small F and I look at the zeros
of that so this is the natural important
scheme of F at l
so then we have this Lemma for which we
have to thank yarak for this we were
stuck for some point or this at this
level
so if we have if you have a local scheme
supported at L that is a polar to F that
all works exists another scheme or maybe
it's the same but there always exists
the scheme contained in Z that is the
product to F such that our Z Prime the
new one is the natural polar scheme of
some g capital G where G is as this
relation with f so f is the partial of G
so this says that we can choose our
gamma the gamma that we are looking at
to be the natural Opera scheme of Sanji
then
if we have this if f is a partial of G
then we look at the de-omogenization and
can show that these two guys at the same
degree detail so this Fiji is going to
be is gonna play the role of the G in
the in here
okay so it is Fiji is uh is our G
and I mean it's quite easy to show that
zvg is contained in gamma and it is a
polar 2f
okay so now we have this preposition
that tells us the relation between the S
and the gi's so I the gis are each one
of the gis I add sorry I have to go each
one of the gi's
is a is supported on I mean it defines
the scheme that is supported on
different points
and and they have the same degree detail
of small F but small f is different for
every point because I have to the
homogenize f for Independence on the
point where I'm localizing it
okay
so the next thing to do that we have to
do if we want to if we want to to find
the dimension of the cactus variety
is the two that now we want to
parameterize all the polynomial G who's
a fine a polar scheme at certain given
length so up until now we have nothing
about degree three no nothing
yeah yeah the theory is all about degree
three I mean these things are gonna I
mean there's nothing that does that
tells us that is not going to work for
any D except computation okay that's
good
um
yeah yeah I'm not using I'm just we we
did it for degree three because then the
the the the complexity of the
complication is really growing
so by our proposition is the same thing
or parametrying the family of cubic
Tails F of some G's
so what time is saying so I take
so I there's a c r r l is so I fix l in
the veronese variety I look at all the
schemes of length at most are supported
at L I take all the span of them and
they take the Union
okay
so this by the preposition above by the
previous position is the same thing of
looking at the forms that has the same
the fixed degree
detail with certain number of partials
and then we will take the union of this
crl by varying l in the linear forms and
then the cactus variety will turn out to
be the closure of the Union of the join
of all these wri where the sum of the ri
sum up to R
so what I want what I want to do now is
to parameterize the set of this
polynomial and the times that I've just
said is I want to parameterize the
family of cubic Tails F of G
in order to do that I want to find an
invariant
for local Latino gordonstein schemes
that parametrize the cubic Tails now I'm
passing to kubica
of polynomials that Define a scheme with
that given invariant
and if I can find that invariant I want
to to find those which is the one that
find that defines the biggest family I
mean I don't want to compute all those
Dimensions if I can find the biggest one
I'm fine and I can anticipate that that
invariant will be the Hilbert function
equipped by asymmetric decomposition
so I rephrase once again this
isomorphism I already I mean I've
already said it but I need it
so T is the space of partials and these
are the partial definition F so this is
actually the space of the partials of f
and I'm gonna use this isomorphism
because I want to interpret a work of
yarubino so yarubino showed that this TF
is local that is one maximal ideal and
so it took two different filtrations in
TF one is the degree D filtration the
degree filtration sorry and
many times
I'm going fast
for someone like myself maybe for
experts it's not true fast
okay so now I look at this at this ring
I want to take two different filtration
one is the degree filtration and the
other is this lower filtration
if I don't have any assumption F they
are different these two filtrations
and by that isomorphism I want to
interpret
these two filtrations in terms of
filtration of of order filtration and
degree filtration in fact the if I take
the maximal ideal
it's the degree ice power of the maximal
ideal is sent by that isomorphism into
partial of order at least I of f
where the order of a parser is the
largest order of some partial such that
Prime of f is larger disorder such that
F Prime is that V of s
while this loyal ideal is sent to into
the partial of degree at most I minus
one of f
but at isomorphism
so I can rephrase these two filtration
this one and this one
by using filtration on the order and the
degree
so I have an order filtration
and degree filtration they are the same
as before but that isomorphism
so since f is not homogeneous those two
filtrations are different
but but
if I look at successive quotient I mean
there's two question they are isomorphic
I'm just saying that then
so I have this isomorphism
in terms of the the order and the degree
filtration
now if I take I mean this is just a
notation this is the partial of degree
at most I and order at least D minus I
minus a
so I look at those questions I mean it's
it's kind of difficult to read here but
I mean
you'll understand why I am doing that so
this is the partial of order
of degree at most high and Order D minus
Simon sa and these are the others so I
switched the role of I and a and I
questioned by these two things
I mean I get this isomorphism why I'm
saying that because this isomorphism
allow us to say that the the upper
function of the two filtration so I have
two different filtration I can associate
two different table functions but
because of this isomorphism those two
filtration are dual to each other
that means that our Rebel function now I
took the one of the degree but I could
have taken also the one of the order it
it has some symmetric decomposition
where this Delta a are exactly the
dimension of these spaces here
and this turns out to be symmetric
around this value okay let me see in an
example what I'm doing okay because here
we get crazy I take a simple example my
f as I said is not homogeneous anymore
now and this is a polynomial in two
variables degree three I take all the
partials of this polynomial
and as you see I have uh in degree zero
I have only one okay it appears twice
but I have only this one in degree one I
have X1 and X2 and this is this two in
degree three in degree 2 sorry I have X1
square and this is this one and in
degree three I have only after this is
this one so this is our variable
function
now I said that I want to to give the
symmetric the composition of this silver
function and this is the following this
is the estimated decomposition so this
row
is symmetric around its middle
and this row is symmetric around this
one in general when we have longer
function you get something that it is on
the anti-diagonal is zero
below and there the rows are symmetric
around their non-zero part okay and so
which is the meaning of these two row
um you can see this from these two so
you see these two is splitted in one
plus one
this is because this two was responsible
of was because we had two forms of
degree in departure we have two guys of
degree one but one comes from a partial
of order one and the other one comes
from a partial of order two
okay
so I mean it's more complicated than
that because as you see here I have
questions so I have to look at a partial
of order and degree blah blah blah but
just to have an idea so here is not only
the degree that is playing a role but
also the the order of the functions
so this is our invariant
the invariant that will that we are
looking at
not only the eBay function but also this
symmetric the composition that takes
care also of the
of the order of our partial
so the next step is to characterize the
polynomials f with the given symmetry
decomposition for label functions so I
want to fix the Symmetry the composition
of the evil function I want to see and I
want to characterize the polynomial with
that symmetric the composition
so I'm saying that if I take a general
cubic form with even local Cactus rank
of rank so even even Iran
I can always write it in this form
where F3
is uh is the degree three part of f in
without x0
okay so X1 and x and x m minus 1 are the
variables that appearing in this F3 and
they are what they are
and then here I have x0 times something
of degree 2 and this something of degree
2 is is always a product of a linear
form in the same variables of F3 and the
form in any other variable linear from
any other variable
then you have x 0 squared times one and
F1 is can be any linear form and then I
have x 0 Cube
times the constant actors attractive
than any forms or sum of products F2 is
2 is a product of linear forms or a sum
of products
I mean this is a product of leader forms
yeah
saying that it's projectly the
equivalent to this I mean I can always
arrive there
and so one can count the dimension of
this guy and it has called I mentioned n
minus one choose two plus one in the
space of cubic forms and I can do the
analogs for the auth case
and in the old case it turns out I have
the same guys this F3 x 0 square F2 and
this last part but I also have these two
guys
that is X N times X1 square and x0 times
x and 2 square
and I can also count the dimension of
this form
okay
so
uh
yes
so now now we want to show which
invariant
so this was to
so the the two slides this one and this
one
where to show this characterization so
fix the other function I can always
arrive in this two situation either this
this one in the even case or in the out
case
now now I want to show which invariant
have the biggest family of cubic tails
so I have my crl that once again is the
uh so I fixed the support L and I take
all the scheme of length at most are
supported at L and the span of the
scheme the union they parameterize the
family of cubic telesbeth and by the
preposition we add this is the same
thing of this set that are the forms of
fixed cubic tails and certain number of
partials
and now I'm gonna split this
by fixing the ilber function
decomposition
so I'm gonna write this as the union of
all those
set that have fixed
degree three Tails this number of
partial and fixed silver function
decomposition and I want to look which
one of these I have the biggest
attains the biggest dimension okay and
so the biggest dimension for this will
give an upper Bound for this
for for the dimension of this space here
that's the same of this
and then so the the the the the guy is
that gives the the the biggest
um
the biggest Dimension are the following
one for the even case
the ilber function the composition is
simply this one
so one and minus one and minus one and
one
while for the odd case the Elder
function the composition that gives the
um it gives the maximum is this one so
yeah the bunch of ones and then I have
this decomposition here
and these are the dimension not going
into the details of the of these numbers
so I have this uh this value that's the
maximum now this is the maximum and so
now you understand I'm almost done
so the cactus we said is the closure of
the Union of the join of this WR where
the WR where the pleasure of the unit of
the crr that
or these are those with the support on
the same linear form
and I wrote them as the union of those
with a fixer dealer function
we found the maximum for this
set
and this provides an upper Bound for
this dimension
so the largest component for example in
of this in the even case is the Union as
L varies of this protective variety
who's the fine corner isomorphic to this
V
to be to end because it's even the even
K is it
so a parametrization of this of these
guys is this Dimension minus one plus n
okay the same dimension of this minus 1
plus 1 and similarly for the odd case
but now one is a problem then the
problem is that the parametrization may
not be genetically finite
so this formula
can give only upper Bound for for for
the dimensions
so one what I have to show that they are
not
they are not
um that they are actually one-to-one
that the parameterization are one-to-one
so it turns out that when B is even
that when we have we are in the even
Cactus trunk
there is a unique linear form where I
that I look at the support such that the
natural a polar scheme of f supported a
debt linear form as precisely the length
that we are looking at
while in the odd case we can't say the
same unfortunately but we can have a
polynomial of degree 4
whose
partial I mean in that case there is a
unique L again such that f is the
demogenization
and the demogenization of f sorry is the
the degree three tale of aquatic
polynomial whose natural Opera scheme
has fixed length
so this actually means that for
for for the even case if we want to
compute the cactus rank we can always
find some l in such a way that the local
Cactus rank computes the cactus rank
because the natural Opera scheme is
going to play this role and I'm also
saying that he's gonna play it for a
unique l
while in the odd case we have to look at
the scheme that the natural Opera scheme
to Aquatic that is not a
I mean I'm just saying that there's no
natural Opera scheme to F that plays
this road that allow us to compute the
cactus rank via local Opera scheme
it's okay here we are done because now
if the the
parametization is genetically one-to-one
then I can actually say that the two
dimensions are the same and then I can
go through all these procedures since I
compute all this maximum I can go back
and compute all this Dimension and get
the dimension of the cactus rank
and that's it
thank you
plenty of time for questions
can you go back to the slide the
statement of the theorem
it was kind of about
so for example if you know what the
components of detectors for ADR and
examples no I mean we just focus on the
dimension
you know the smallest example where
there is a second component yeah
what is the smallest value of R between
14 say and 18. so if you go up 14 15
what's the smallest R well there is
actually a second one
right I mean I I don't know I mean we
don't study the the we just we just
focus on the dimension we don't I don't
know
interaction computation well they're
parametrizing it right so when R is
the same Dimension yeah so one the c cap
variety is irreducible
so I'm asking or we're trying to ask
when is the first case where we know for
sure that there's something in the
cactus variety that's not in the secant
variety
or do we have to wait till we get to 18
to be sure well the dimension
calculations come from parameterizing it
so you could ask if the parameter the
base if the base of the parameterization
has more than one component that would
be the start
I could call it what's going on
positions
um
so if you ask just for the base there
are guarantine non-smovable things below
it but it's not easy to save the second
is not like uh I mean if their spans are
not contained in other C Cups so for 14
there are non-smoothable gorenstein
schemes but we do not know where they
spawn off a new component
the component is small
and it's not clear whether the other
thing is contained in the Bitcoin but
that's okay even for the helmet scheme
of points if you have eight points in
four space the extra component is lower
Dimension yeah but there's a good reason
for that
you're saying there's not a good reason
for this
at least
you know that I'm saying that we don't
understand whether it is
also get a proof that when this free is
a bigger number than other components
appear
this one's a perfect standing here so
this upon a scheme is that the same as
the macquarium system
is
foreign
is that true
scheme of length
B plus one so m b plus one is zero
so yes I think yeah that's your yeah
so I'd have to philosophical question
you start with things that are
homogeneous and you decompose the sounds
of power so the new forms everything is
homogeneous but at some point you decide
to keep homogenize yeah
it doesn't matter which way you be
homogenized but still there is some sort
of arbitrary choice
homogeneization but is that necessary I
mean somehow it feels
uh you know it always feels that the
projective space is better than the A5
space but then at some point here you
decide yeah that the point that's that's
one of the main points I mean because we
have local schemes that's the that's the
fact that the the the the the the the
ring the TF purp is local so it's
supported at some points and then if I
want to work locally it's better to work
fine I mean that that's the main
philosophical response I think is that
you want to always work infinitesimally
if you can and so she's working in a
testimony
but then that's that's hard to deal
harder to work with it yeah
I think matsubishi has an interpretation
that you can do everything without the
homogenization if you eat that at the
end it is more complicated so I think
I mean the idea comes from the fact that
that scheme is local so it's this it
turns out to be natural to look at the
Fine Things
from this you can say what's the general
Cactus rank of a cubic form I think you
can say which is the the rang which is
the the cactus rank of a general form
yeah the one that fills the ambient
space that is this two n plus two oh oh
that's
the
pubic cancers
no clue I mean for for that I mean you
you have to use I mean here a polarity
is a kind of important thing if you pass
to tensor not symmetric one you have to
use a complete different notion of a
polarity whatever it means in the not
symmetric case so
as I said before is completely different
yeah
there's a third notion namely the
variety given by the rank constraints on
the hunger Matrix
how does it fit in can you just remind
me how that so if I had the uncle Matrix
or catalyptica
so the
the cactus rank is actually
um
I mean the the the ankle the anchor rank
is going to give you the cactus rank
um
I think the ankle determinental variety
is fewer conditions than the cactus
range so it's even large so secant
contain the cactus containment
can you say in this range
so well per cubics it fills almost right
away two one split right there's no
they're not many epileptics so and
so when R is even here
it means that you will get
just one
I look at that the one local scheme that
computes the the cactus rank yeah
foreign
whose cubic tails is f on one point yeah
is there a good description special
point
some point
um
you mean of this even and odd thing
no I mean I I I try to find the a good
explanation at least for myself but I
mean it turns out from the proof but I
don't I don't have a deep understanding
of this phenomena
together
other questions